it's kind of like using money to make
more money and by generate seems pretty
counterintuitive exact twice fuller for
reason TV and here at Democratic
National Convention the Republicans made
the national debt a centerpiece of their
National Convention we're going to see
if Democrats are also concerned about
the national debt and if so what they'd
like to see done about it we're talking
about the national debt today it's not
an important issue to you certainly is
the national debt it certainly is it's
the national debt important to Democrats
absolutely I think the national debt is
all very important
we're sixteen trillion in debt
approximately we're spending about a
trillion more a year than we actually
take in so how do we close that trillion
a year gap the deficit first of all if
you increase taxes let me take time to
deal with this right quick the
Republican says that President Barack is
going to increase taxes but they don't
say it's for the rich one percenters his
plan seems to be to raise taxes on
anyone making over $200,000 a year well
it causes me grief only because I
wouldn't actually close the deficit it
would only cut it by about 90 billion
but it'd make things a little more fair
see we in Wisconsin are very big unfair
simply raising the taxes on the richest
people is not going to close the deficit
should everyone else be paying more of
their fair share as well taxes is not
the only issue that's out there it's an
issue that gets to the attention of some
folks but I think we've got to figure
out how to stimulate this economy and
put people back to work
investing in our infrastructure it's
kind of like using money to make more
money and by generating is pretty
counterintuitive it made perhaps it does
but I think it's really the way we need
to go what exactly has he done to try to
pull us out of debt because it seems
like he's you know just spent a spent
over quite a bit of money and put us
more in debt well as you know it takes
money to make money
President Obama and others in his
administration said if we don't pass the
stimulus unemployment is going to shoot
up above 8% well we passed the stimulus
and we're still above 8% so how is that
a success
well you're looking at it it was just on
the money who knows what the future was
going to hold how in the world can you
say President Obama did not do the
things he said when he tried and they
cock-blocked him their cock-blocking
they cock-blocked they did that on every
bill he presented the wall street bill
the stimulus bill cock-blocked the
stimulus bill would you be okay with
cutting back some government spending
for instance well we depend on the on
the government spending you know I
certainly think there's glut
what sort of reforms or programs would
you see like to see scaled back that's
why we have congressman you ask them
that question what are some of the
things you think we can't afford to cut
back on in terms of government spending
I think we make expenditures subsidies
on energy that perhaps you know I think
the energy companies are doing pretty
well on their own that are we talking
about subsidies on all energy companies
both green energy and oil company I
think the ones that are emerging
technologies that could use research
dollars for example so you don't want to
cut subsidies across the board not
necessarily across the board about
reforming some of the entitlements
Medicare Social Security
those are big drivers of debt sure you
know again I am in the healthcare
industry 60% of everyone on Medicaid is
your grandmother in mine you're a young
person I assume you want to look forward
to your Social Security someday I'm not
counting on my Social Security one day
if the national debt kind of collapses
the whole program you know and that's
wonderful but right now our generation
and others are certainly counting on it
you're advocating another stimulus do
you think that's what a Obama should put
forward not necessarily your with Reason
magazine I'm just a party chair we don't
have to be reasonable all the time